HONOUR AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KASIA WHO CAN SEE OFF THE GET .
MOORE
HE WILL CURL INSIDE THE LINE TH.
IT'S AN OFFSIDE CALL. LETTING IR
ANDERSON WHO NEARLY GOING ON AH.
H, AND THE KINGS
DOUBLE THE LEAD. TO THE RIGHT S.
TAVARES KNOCKED THE NEUTRAL
ZONE.
D
MIGHT TEST HIS PATIEPLAY.
TWO FOR FOUR AGAINST
RIELLY NOW WITH MATTHEWS TRYING
TO GET AVAILABLE.Y KEPT THE PUC,
KEPT THE MOVEMENT FROM THE HALF
WALL.
TREVOR MOORE DEFLECTS IT DOWN
INTO THE LEAFS ZONE.
CAMPBELL OM FROM DEEP IN YOUR ON
ZONE.
THIS ONE STARTS OFF THENLEY CUP
RUN.
JUST ONE POINT AGAINST THE LEAFS
IN THE SEVEN-GAME SER HERE.
DEFINITELY DIRECTED IT THERE BUT
CAMPBELL THOUGHT HE HAD IT ON
HIS PAD AND SLOWING DOWN ANDS
THAT THE DELAY HERE IS
FOLLOWING UP IS KALIYEV.
AND MARNER W WHERE'S A GOOD JOBG
THIS PUCK ALIVE A LITTLE REVERSE
NYLANDER.
THINKING OF PTAVARES AND NYLANDE
HIS SHOT DEFLECTING WIDE OF THE.
AND WATCH AS HE ENGAGES,EEP.
THERE'S NYLANDER.FIRST.